the Joe Rogan experience look I saw
conspiracy theories that Connor through
the fire or a cowboy through the fight
with Colin and I had my cousins like oh
I can't believe cowboy would do that I'm
gonna do what you want crap do what
people are crazy yeah yeah yeah I I was
upset at Steven Naismith and I made a
video man come on listen Steven Naismith
I guess I should respond right
you're a very entertaining guy I like
you a lot and I appreciate the props he
gave me in that video but you're wrong
yeah cowboy got cowboy got [ __ ] up
with those shoulders in the clinch he
had Connors arms tied up and they're in
tight spaces
Connor dips low and slams this bone of
his shoulder into the nose and he's at
the beginning of the round Connors a
[ __ ] super explosive guy super
explosive all muscle just [ __ ] pulled
tight at the beginning of the fight and
just bang bang he got off good shots and
cowboy was confused I think he's
flustered flustered I I don't think that
those shots maybe rocked him they posed
an act that could rock I guess he's got
blood pouring out of his nose so he's
not breathing out of his nose now and
then all the sudden he's like [ __ ] my
nose has already [ __ ] up and he hasn't
even punched me right you know it was it
was unusual like I could see if someone
has a peripheral understanding of the
sport and you see that having like come
on man
or even guys like Mike Bisping like Mike
Bisping he was like [ __ ] shoulder
strikes come on shoulders right now but
that said Mike Bisping is without a
doubt one of the toughest human beings
has ever walked the face of the planet
like if you lost an ear but ah you got
another yeah yeah it's with one eye come
on he doesn't give a [ __ ] you fought a
giant chunk of his career against the
best fighters no we're including win
that title with one eye yeah Michael
Bisping is a [ __ ] dyed-in-the-wool
Savage yeah so if he's like shoulder
strikes that said the soldier strike
didn't end the fight the shoulder
strikes definitely got him off on the
wrong foot then cowboy threw a kick to
Connors arms and then Connor can't
counter with a head kick rock cowboy
see his legs go and then Connor hits him
with pistons so hard people could say it
was a work he broke his [ __ ] orbital
bone yeah and then but Steven Naismith
said that he felt like cowboy quit he
did not quit he got smashed someone quit
again their nose broke and rocked and a
broken orbital you can't say he quit
it's also who you're talking about
you're talking about a guy was the most
fights in the UFC the most finishes in
the UFC the most headkick knockouts in
the UFC the most the most bonuses in the
UFC cowboy is a [ __ ] legend he is a
as tough as they come
he's lost before every human can lose
especially your fighting guys like
Darren Till and Jorge Maz Vidale and and
these [ __ ] animals that he's fighting
he's fighting the cream of the crop or
Connor and Connor broke it literally
broke his face he broke his nose and he
broke his orbital bone so so Steven
Naismith responded and then Connor
responded yeah I seen Connor told him to
apology yes that's right he is right I
mean give Connor the credit a little bit
I think the problem is Steven Naismith
who's a very entertaining guy and is
very knowledgeable about other sports
this is not his wheelhouse and also that
style of dismissing athletes and putting
people down like some kind of made his
name that's how you made his name and
it's fun to listen to he's he's a fun
guy to listen to yeah he talks great
[ __ ] you know but I wonder I mean I'm
sure basketball players are kind of
saying the same stuff we're saying when
he's criticizing basketball players
though or football players you know you
mean oh I'm sure I'm sure I mean I don't
know too much about that Jamie you're a
sports fan right did they criticize him
too he's respected for sure yeah yeah
but to the show he's on it's like every
day he's got to wake up and give his
take and they gotta talk about it for an
hour too and a lot of the take it's like
the controversy is like good yeah they
gotta talk about yeah and he had a radio
show for three hours he did after that
so like yeah Blackhawks all day long
right yeah and you know and he's
entertaining that's what people like to
hear like to see here's someone
passionate you hear him and Teddy Teddy
Atlas yeah argue after the Conor
McGregor Floyd made with a fight yeah
daddy acts like Conor McGregor made the
best chef in the world be a [ __ ]
fast-food cutter that's basically how
they're like back and for the two of
them yelling and arguing it's very
entertaining yeah I just think yeah
that's it that's his position all right
I just think that this sport demands
more appreciation more respect and it
demands a higher level of reverence to
the athletes who literally put their
lives on the line it's a different I
don't think you have to say the guy quit
to descript describe what happened no
you could just talk about what Connor
did that was so special he looked the
guy finds tricky ways to do things and
those shoulder strikes look we've seen
guys do shoulder shrugs before but we
never saw anybody do it successfully but
you got to think about the UFC is a lot
of what happens in the UFC is someone at
all these fights finally does something
and then other people start doing that
thing like you remember when no one was
throwing front kicks to the face
no one yep all the sudden Anderson
knocks out Vitor who's like one of the
elite of the elite strikers knocks him
out with the front kick of the face and
you're like what no but and then you see
everyone trying it nobody ever did it I
don't remember anybody ever even in
kickboxing people very rarely through a
front kick to the face just wasn't you
know they would teep the right thing but
that even teeps to the face it was
immoral arrange thing yeah all you would
like push in his face right like you
very rarely unless someone caught it
perfect so I gotta get knocked out with
like a snap front kick with the ball of
the foot now almost like an uppercut the
way it comes off yeah dude it's a
[ __ ] devastating technique yeah when
done correctly I mean Justin Buckholtz
got a KO with it outside of the UFC
that's devastating lyoto machida did
that jumping front kick to Randy cool
right yeah nice Randy Couture with a
[ __ ] front kick to the face that's a
legit technique but then you see
everybody doing that like low calf kicks
right yeah first guy I ever saw do it
was Benson Benson really Benson
Henderson really got into those locales
me those are rough man but now everybody
throws those things you guys think of
how many years went by before people
were not throwing low calf kicks I
guarantee you now when people get tied
up in the clinch and
holding someone with double over hook
sore whatever I don't remember how
Connor had ahold of our cowboy
over/under right yeah when someone's
tied up in the clinch an you can't
strike you're gonna see guys this is a
bone man it's a [ __ ] bone right there
and it's just something to distract him
you know to look to move to something
else but this where your shoulder at the
top of your shoulder that's [ __ ] hard
yeah yeah you know it's not the ideal
thing to strike with but when there's
nothing else there there's something
there yeah it's I could see how Steven
Smith would not think that that was
effective I could see but for me it was
clearly effective there were hard shots
there's a lot of power behind it there's
a lot of explosion Conor dipping his
level and coming up and slamming into it
it was correct kind of crazy but even if
you take that away the head kick and the
punches to finish I mean yeah it's quick
there he's not quit he got beat down he
got beat down smashed by a guy who rises
to the occasion the Cowboys had problems
in the past with these really big fights
and yeah he looked nervous as [ __ ] and
he talks about it openly
there was a video that they played which
I don't think I should have played
before the fight because he you had to
hear that so they're playing a video of
him describing how nervous he gets
before fights and how he throws up right
that's done and also about how he's kind
of faking it Tennant like he's fine but
he's not inside I'm freaking the [ __ ]
out they played that before he fought
I'm like why think about even more yes
that's what I was thinking I'm I'll say
[ __ ] he does not need to hear this
that's why I'm in the locker room when
I'm gonna lock room and the TV's on I'm
always like turn that volume down I
don't want hear anybody talking about my
fight turn that [ __ ] down
good for you good for you I mean I'm
cognizant to that when I see a guy in
the locker room and I'm talking and I
try to pump him up yeah I want them to
feel good
[Applause]